Death is as commonplace in film as green
screens and fake facial hair. But in some cases,
there's a lot of confusion surrounding
the death of a character. From mysterious
disappearances to off-screen mortalities,
these movie deaths were never truly explained.
In Indiana Jones and the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull,
Sean Connery didn't return
as Professor Henry Jones,
though he'd proven a welcome addition to the Indy
franchise in Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade.
"Dad?"
"What?"
"Dad!"
"What?!"
"Head for the fireplace!"
We don't get a lot of information on how
Professor Jones died, but Indy confirms it
in Kingdom of the Crystal Skull while looking
at a photograph of his father on his desk.
We're apparently meant to assume Henry died
of natural causes, but the events of The Last
Crusade beg for a more specific explanation. In
the film, the villainous Walter Donovan shoots
Indy's father, leaving the Holy Grail as Henry's
only possible salvation. Indy finds the Grail,
heals Henry's wound with it, and has him
drink from the cup. Earlier in the movie,
we're told the knights who discovered the
Grail were alive 150 years after finding it,
meaning the artifact bestows longer life. Taking
one little drink might not grant Henry 150 more
years, but it seems reasonable to assume it'd give
him at least a little more time than expected.
Perhaps offscreen he went on another
adventure with Indy that he shouldn't have?
Sean Connery's Henry Jones isn't the only elder
academic missing from Indiana Jones and the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull. Museum curator
and Marshall College dean of students Marcus
Brody is missing as well, though the real-world
reason for his absence was incredibly tragic.
Denholm Elliott, the actor who played Brody
in Raiders of the Lost Ark and Indiana Jones
and the Last Crusade, sadly passed away
in 1992 from AIDS-related tuberculosis.
It's never mentioned exactly how Marcus dies
in Indy's narrative, but he isn't forgotten
in Kingdom of the Crystal Skull. After Marcus'
passing, a statue is erected in his honor on the
campus of Marshall College. When Indy and Mutt
lead KGB agents on a chase through the campus,
one of the cars crashes into Brody's memorial
bust. That's when the head of the statue breaks
off, crashes through the car's windshield,
and lands in the lap of one of the KGB agents.
The Autobot known as Sideswipe isn't the most
visible Transformer. He makes his first appearance
in Transformers: Revenge of the Fallen, showing
up in Shanghai where he kills the Decepticon
Sideways. Sideswipe returns in Transformers:
Dark of the Moon, and while he survives the
second film, he's absent in both Transformers: Age
of Extinction and Transformers: The Last Knight.
We don't see him killed or hear anything
about why he isn't around anymore.
Believe it or not, the minor hero's death is
revealed not on the big screen or even in a
behind-the-scenes feature, but on a collectible
trading card that reveals he was killed between
movies. Of course, if it's only explained
in a trading card set, that means a lot of
viewers who only know him from the movies can
imagine Sideswipe is still out there somewhere.
One of the most confusing "non-explanation
explanations" for a death comes in the
conclusion to the Star Wars prequels,
with 2005's Revenge of the Sith.
While Anakin Skywalker is being turned into a
slow-breathing cyborg, his clandestine wife,
Padme Amidala, dies for extremely vague
reasons. After giving birth to twins,
Padme appears to be in perfect health.
Nevertheless, her life is still slipping
away. So why is she dying? Well, as a
medical droid explains to Obi-Wan Kenobi,
"We don't know why. She's lost the will to live."
Even if we forget for a moment that deeming
a person to have "lost the will to live"
seems a fairly deep revelation for a Droid,
we're left with two sentences that literally
contradict one another. The droid first says it
doesn't know why she's dying, then it says why
she's dying. It would be as if it said, "We don't
know why she's dying. Also, she was decapitated."
Still, "she lost the will to live" isn't
much of an explanation. We can dig deeper
ourselves and theorize that it's because
Anakin broke her heart with his betrayal,
so she just didn't want to
live anymore. That said,
she also knew she had twin babies on the way,
which seems like something worth living for.
So, the real medical explanation for exactly
why Padme died might remain a mystery forever.
After the TV series Twin Peaks was canceled,
the prequel film Twin Peaks: Fire Walk with
Me was released in 1992. The film opens on the
investigation into the death of Theresa Banks,
conducted by Agent Chet Desmond and his partner
Agent Stanley. Their investigation abruptly ends
in the Fat Trout Trailer Park when Agent
Desmond discovers the victim's ring under
a trailer. We see him reach for it,
and that's it. We never see him again.
It could be that Desmond isn't dead. Instead, he
may have been pulled into an otherworldly place
known as the Black Lodge. The original TV series
ends when Agent Dale Cooper is imprisoned there,
and in Fire Walk with Me, when Cooper
investigates Desmond's disappearance,
he finds the words "Let's Rock" written
across the windshield of Desmond's car — a
phrase spoken in the TV series by a Black Lodge
resident, the mysterious Man from Another Place.
"Let's rock!"
In spite of the series getting a second lease
on life with 2017's Twin Peaks: The Return,
Desmond's fate isn't mentioned. In an AMA
Reddit session after the miniseries concluded,
co-creator Mark Frost apologetically told fans
that even though the character was discussed,
the showrunners couldn't come up with a way to
bring Desmond back, quote, "from wherever he is."
If all you know of Jack Crawford comes from the
award-winning 1991 film The Silence of the Lambs,
then you might not think he's a very important
character to the franchise. But Crawford is
integral to the Thomas Harris novels that the
movies are based upon, and Scott Glenn plays
him to perfection in the first film. However,
Crawford fails to appear in the 2001 sequel,
Hannibal. In fact, he isn't mentioned at all in
the film's theatrical release. A deleted scene
confirms he died before the film's events, but
it doesn't mention how. In the novel Hannibal,
Crawford dies from a heart attack, but this
happens during the events of the book, not before.
In 2015, Glenn told The A.V. Club both he and
Silence of the Lambs co-star Jodie Foster were
asked to return for Hannibal, but they agreed
doing so could, quote, "ruin a good thing," so
both declined. Still, it's unfortunate director
Ridley Scott was either unwilling or unable to
recast the role — or at least make some room
in the screenplay to explain why Crawford
wasn't around in the theatrical release. Of
course, Glenn is now part of a rich tradition
of acclaimed actors playing Jack Crawford. In
2002, Harvey Keitel took the role of Crawford
in the prequel Red Dragon and Laurence Fishburne
played him in the acclaimed Hannibal TV series.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.